the situation is under control
a reassuring message from the congolese
government after it mistakenly announced
on saturday
that there had been another volcanic
eruption near the eastern city of goma
the false alarm came only a week after
mount near gongo
roared back to life forcing hundreds of
thousands
to flee the area now some are braving
the return home
defying warnings that underground lava
could suddenly arise
anywhere in the region more than a
thousand volcano refugees
left a camp in rwanda on saturday and
queued at the border of the democratic
republic of congo
in the hope of a return to normal life
once more
slowly returning to the city of gomer
many people no longer have
anywhere to call home after the
niregongo volcano
rode back to life several days ago
africa's most active volcano saw
terrified people flee the congolese city
as rivers of lava killed dozens of
people and left tens of thousands
homeless
fears that mount niragongo could become
active again
days after the initial eruption sparked
a mass evacuation
of more than half of gomer's
neighborhoods
people have sought shelter wherever they
could including school classrooms
many said they were struggling to find
enough food and water
as the un called for international aid
however not
everyone fled the area frontline
healthcare workers stayed behind to care
for their patients
this new mother was in labor when the
alarm was sounded once more
we took an oath to remain by our
patient's side we couldn't run away
and follow those who fled we had to
first observe
and see who among the population would
be the last to leave
and see if we were going to flee if the
situation
became more complicated
the natural beauty of mount nida gongo
betrays its volatile nature
leaving thousands to pick up the pieces
and rebuild their lives
you